wir lernen erstens kontrolliere deine
gefühle
zweitens macht ihr bewusst was
eigentlich die einschränkungen seines
denkens sind
drittens überlege dir ob vielleicht der
andere recht haben könnte
was ich an diesem es sei wirklich so
ungeheuer zeitgemäß finde es so dieser
gedanke überlegt doch einfach mal die
anderen könnten recht haben ich weiß
dass du dein nicht so wahnsinnig ich
finde wirklich dass es sich sehr lohnt
dieses buch zu lesen
gerade weil es ganz ganz viele
anknüpfungspunkte hat an unsere heutige
zeit und das hat mich einfach so
erschreckt dass george orwell vor 70
jahren schon ganz viele tendenzen und
debatten unserer zeit vorweggenommen hat
wohnt jetzt in diesem essay über
nationalismus der titel sagt es
eigentlich und dann auch wieder nicht
versteht unter nationalismus eine
bestimmte art des denkens nehme ich das
denken nach dem schema ich mit meiner in
gruppe habe bestimmte eigenschaften und
die sind anders als die anderen da
draußen eine feindliche abgrenzung einer
gruppe zu einer anderen gruppe das was
uns eigentlich heutzutage in unserer
gesellschaft am meisten bewegt ich denke
man kann ganz viele identitäts
politische debatten darauf zurück bringt
das quasi immer mitgedacht wird als teil
der eigenen sogenannten identität dass
da eine differenz besteht zu den anderen
genau aber nicht nur das das wäre ja
neutral sondern dass die eigene gruppe
auch die bessere gruppe ist das betonen
der differenz geht für mich schon gegen
den anspruch den ich habe von einem
universellen menschenbild also die
vorstellung dass das was uns verbindet
eigentlich viel gewichtiger ist als das
was uns trennen da sie schnell dann
flöten wenn ihr den unterschied in den
vordergrund meiner eigenen
selbstdefinition stille und das ist gut
denn das ist wichtig er sagt wir können
nicht glauben dass wir über
befangenheiten hinweg kommen sondern wir
müssen uns die einfach nur bewusst
machen also wir müssen nicht davon
ausgehen dass sie es schaffen
tatsächlich unbefangen zu werden aber
wir müssen uns bei allem was wir sagen
und denken immer dieser befangenheit
so seien und was ich so interessant
finde auch da also insofern ist dieser
es wirklich extrem hell und ja auch da
sagt er ja nicht so nach dem motto ja ja
die weniger gebildeten menschen sind das
problem sondern er sagt das problem ist
auch die intelligenz jahren ja also die
gebildeten leute die alle denken sie
hätten recht und die nicht mehr in der
lage sind darüber nachzudenken dass es
eben diese befangenheit gibt weil sie
das nicht mehr spiegel und im
schlussteil gibt es ja eine art
anleitung handlungsempfehlungen wie kann
man dieses problem bewältigen dass man
selber befangen ist in so einer
ideologischen plagen wir lernen erster
kontrollieren deine gefühle versuche mit
dem verstand zu denken
zweitens macht ihr bewusst was
eigentlich die einschränkungen seines
denkens sind also was sind die
vorurteile die du sowieso schon immer
mit mir rumschleppen
drittens überlege dir ob vielleicht der
andere recht haben könnte
ende